Welcome, everybody.
My name is Ben and this is Sachin.
And we're incredibly excited to talk to you today about
the future of app development with Raefen.
So I'm sure everybody in this room is probably familiar
with the fact that agentic coding is really transforming application
development and it's really democratizing who can build applications.
So I coach AU 5 girls soccer team, the Mia
Hamsters with a very good friend, Brent.
And Brent is not a software engineer by any means,
but a few months ago he discovered a gente coding
and he just started like spitting out applications.
So he's building season stats apps, he's building snack schedules,
he's building practice plans.
And for me as somebody who got into software development
because I love to make things, it's incredibly fun and
inspiring to see the brinks of the world all of
a sudden become makers.
And I think that's the power of agentic coding.
It has the ability to turn the brinks of the
world into makers and it has the ability to turn
existing software engineers into kind of super makers.
But as you go from coding a kids soccer app
into a corporate environment where you're dealing with like real
customer data and real compliance needs, all of a sudden
sort of the opportunity of vibe coding, the promise of
it starts to sort of fall apart.
And that so if you're a software engineer, apps in
the enterprise, you find they need more than just kind
of good vibes.
As a software engineer, you need to build databases with
real authentication.
You need to configure back end services.
You need to safely connect to existing customer data, and
you need to be able to do all of this
while following your company's compliance and governance rules.
And if you're on the IT admin side of things,
it's even more complicated.
In this new world, you have to make sure that
only the right people have the right access to the
right data.
And it's really on you to make sure that you're
maintaining your company's security and compliance posture.
And that's why we built Rayfind.
So Rayfind is the back end for this new AI
coding era.
It makes it easy for a human and an agent
to define an entire back end in code, so it's
an SDK.
In CLI, you can author the back end in code,
so that includes your database, your functions, your storage, your
access policies are all defined in code.
So it's easy for both the agent and a human
to be able to understand and operate it.
And when you're ready to deploy that application, you can
do so with just a single CLI command and deploy
it right to Microsoft Fabric, where all those resources are
provisioned and managed for you and you get enterprise grade
security compliance right out of the gate.
So let's stop sort of talking around it.
Let's do a quick demo of what this actually looks
like.
Let's say I work for Zaba, a home improvement store,
and we have a CEO who's very excitable and he
is super pumped about launching a new home delivery service.
So for the first time, I can now get my
hammers and nails and everything else delivered directly to my
door, which is great.
But now we need a whole suite of applications to
make that possible.
So we need a application for our delivery service drivers.
We need apps for the management to be able to
actually like monitor how this service is performing.
And as the software engineer, all of a sudden all
of this falls on me to build.
So fortunately I have Raefen and I can open up
my VS Code editor with a terminal window open and
with a simple Rafe and create command, I can start
to create a project that is built to have not
only a beautiful front end like agents are so good
at, but also a great back end as well.
So I'll go ahead and walk through the setup and
it's going to ask me to choose a template.
And right now we have a couple of basic starter
templates.
To begin with, I'll go ahead and choose the blank
app template and I'll give the project a name.
In this case I'll just call it Delivery App.
And at this point it is scaffolding my project, so
it's adding all the files I need to build both
the front end and the back end of the application,
including the agent instructions on how to use the Rayfin
SDK and CLI.
So now I'll just CD into my project and at
this point I'm going to call Rayfin up.
And what that command is doing is it's actually going
and provisioning all of those resources right in Fabric.
So I now have my database and my application running
in Fabric, and I can now run my local development
environment pointing towards those remote resources.
And so this is where it gets to be fun.
This is where you get to just tell an agent
the application that you actually want to go build.
So in this case, I'm going to go tell it
to build that delivery app.
So I'm going to say build the delivery app.
And this is going to be for the Zaba delivery
drivers, and I want them to be able to log
deliveries with photos and item conditions.
And then I want to be able to have customers
be able to actually confirm receipt.
So we'll do a little sort of build demo magic
here, and we're going to jump forward to where we've
actually finished completing that application development with the agent.
Great.
So I have a finished application at this point, and
I can see that it's created a bunch of TypeScript
files that are actually defining my tables and all their
properties right here in code.
And I'm going to go ahead and go visit that
application in Fabric, OK?
So I can see that it built the delivery application
that I was hoping for.
It's let's a driver come to a house like with
a tablet and be able to have a customer actually
sign off and confirm deliveries.
So let's go ahead and do that.
OK, So I've confirmed the delivery, and I could also
open this application outside of the Fabric Chrome so it
gets its own URL as well.
Let's just look at that.
Great.
So I've got the application I want.
Now.
For those of you who are familiar with Fabric, you'll
be familiar with Fabric workspaces, and that's where basically all
of your items and artifacts live.
So that's the nice convenient way of managing all those
items and artifacts.
So let's go to our Zaba workspace, and I can
see that there's a new delivery app artifact that was
created, as well as a child SQL database.
So if I go into that child SQL database, I
should see that new delivery recorded right there in the
database.
So I'll go ahead and click on that and perfect,
I can see that the new delivery item ended up
right there in my SQL database.
OK, so now I'm going to hand it over to
Sachin, who's going to walk in to a bit more
detail of how all of this works under the hood.
Go for it, Sachin.
Thanks, Ben.
All right, so you saw.
How Ben was able to build a complete application with
a front end with a database?
He was able to build it with.
Agent then deploy it into fabric and you know you
got the database spun up etcetera.
So I want to.
Walk you through exactly.
How that happens?
So let's go back.
To the code that Ben's agent generated the delivery class
and there's like a few interesting things to point out
here so the first thing you see is the entity
decorator on the class and that's what tells Raefen that
this is going to be a database table inside fabric
and you also have the property decorators which kind of.
You know hint towards the what will be the type?
Of the column as well as the min, Max kind
of get translated to column constraints on the database itself.
You can also specify.
Relationships, but what's also.
Interesting is.
How do you specify security right so?
Security as well can be done inside code, and so
you can specify a role decorator on top and then
specify a policy function.
And in this case what it's telling you is that
only authenticated users can see deliveries and only their own.
And what if I'm making changes to this data model?
So like say I get rid of a.
Column or I I change the data model entirely, Raefin
will detect that change and we will go and translate
and do the migration for you.
So you don't have to go and manage and maintain
separation migration scripts as well.
So I'm going to walk.
You through the configuration file of YAML and kind of
show you a few more interesting characteristics about Raefin.
So what you notice here?
Is that it's data?
The dialect.
Is Microsoft SQL so.
Currently, when you deploy A Rayfin app into.
Fabric the fabric SQL Server gets.
Spun up and so it uses that as your database
in future.
We will also support.
Other dialects, for example, we'll be bringing in Postgres and
so.
You'll be able to.
Then your application will be able to spin up a.
Postgres, Postgres SQL database.
And and that is just a configuration change, so you
don't have to have like your application code.
The way you declare your entities, the way you do
permissioning, everything remains exactly the same.
Another interesting thing is.
We do.
Deploy the application as a front end and the back
end, right?
So when Ben was building his delivery application, the front
end was in Fabric, the back end was in Fabric.
And that's pretty convenient to go do, but internally?
They deploy a separate thing, so you could.
Have your front end hosted on a different say in
Azure and you could have custom domains etcetera on it.
You can also have applications share the same.
Back end so you could deploy a.
Back end by itself.
And then you could build two different.
Applications on top of it and that's.
What you see here with the scopes.
And so you.
Can have different sort of scopes.
On application A versus.
B.
So you.
Could have application A only read data, while you could
have application B that could read and write data.
To it as well.
And then you also have some authentication options.
So right now.
All apps require Fabric.
Authentication, but in the.
Future we will allow you to public publish.
Apps that are anonymous or.
Use other sort of.
Authentication providers like Gmail etcetera.
So you could imagine a scenario where you're building an
application for an external.
Customer to log.
Into & up and do things, but you want the
data to land into your fabric tenant.
So you know the business users within the organisations could
perform downstream analytics on that data.
But often, So what we saw until now was OK,
you have an, you have an app, and you can
easily spin up a back end, You can spin up
a database, you can read and write from it.
But that's not often where people start.
People want to be able to connect to existing data
that they already have.
They want to be able to operate on that data,
read it and write to it.
And so we have.
Introduced the notion of connectors which allow you.
To connect to any data that is in the fabric,
one link and that can be databases, that can be
warehouses, semantic models and depending on the data source you.
Will be able to also write back to it.
And so you declare that data source into your configuration.
So this is my connector.
I'm kind of connecting to this data source.
We also have agent instructions that help you pull in
these tables and create classes for them.
So you get type safety when dealing with this data.
It also doesn't.
Just pull in.
All of your.
Data so you can have a semantic model with hundreds
of tables, but in this case I'm only interested in
building a view.
For all the details, so it will just.
You know, pull in that schema from from that table.
Kind of.
Create the types for.
It so you can use it in the application.
But it's not.
Always about data, right?
So you want to be.
Able to execute some sort of logic, say you want
to.
Fire off a notification.
You want to go connect to an external service and
you want.
You don't want this code to be running in the
browser, so you want this code to be in the
back end where you can safely inject credentials into it
so you can run it.
And we still let you create and define the function
in TypeScript.
So you can write your TypeScript logic.
Your app can call.
It as if it was just part of its code.
But when you deploy it with rayfin up, it takes
that function block.
It deploys it as a fabric function.
So it runs in a secure sandbox and then you
can go and do that, you know, trigger off that
notification or connect to external services and data.
So what Ben showed?
You earlier was he was starting from.
Scratch, I think he used the built in.
Template and so templates.
Allow you to both like not always start.
From a blank application but it.
Also allows you to standardize.
Applications for your organization.
So maybe your organization is trying to build.
A dashboards and you want them to look.
And.
Behave a particular way.
And you don't want to burn too many tokens or
just.
You know, publishing style guides.
That they will read into.
What you can do is you can create a template
that anyone in the organization can use and templates can
be also checked in into.
A repository.
So you can share with the community so anyone can
reference a template.
That's out there.
To get started really easily, what does the template contain?
So the template might contain.
Tools SO API.
Definitions or MCP servers and then you have agent instructions
that.
Tell you how to go operate these.
Tools to generate additional contexts etcetera.
It also comes with some sample.
Code so your.
Agent is not spending a ton of time scaffolding logic.
It can also contain.
Libraries so.
If you want for example to pull in a.
Particular kind of charting library.
For your data application, you can one of the most
common things enterprise organizations.
Will build as data.
Apps would be dashboards.
And so we partnered with the Power BI team.
To build just that.
So I'd like to invite Sujata on stage to talk
about it.
Thanks, everyone.
So how many here in the audience are excited to
build analytics apps?
Yeah, a few.
And I think the reality is a lot of enterprise
applications tend to start with analytics.
And what Raefen is doing is something really groundbreaking because
for years, applications and analytics lived in separate worlds, right?
You had one team build your analytics stack and you
had another team build your applications.
But Raefen brings that together, and now our data app
template does something really unique because it's allowing you to
build applications directly on your semantic layer.
This means all of the effort that you put into
your semantic model and building your analytic stack can now
be reused for your applications.
And let's talk a little bit more in depth of
what the data app template is.
So if you look at our template, there's three core
components.
1st is a data package.
And what this does is really make sure that we're
normalizing things like the Fabric endpoint connection, how we're doing
query retries, caching.
So a lot of those foundational steps to making sure
you're connecting to your enterprise data and you're querying it.
Well, the data package provides that.
Next, we have a visual package.
So this is using a React and Vega Lite components
to get AI first visuals that are extremely flexible.
And not only that, they have enterprise grade defaults.
So like such invention, this was built by the Power
BI team, which has years of Dataviz experience to really
make sure that these visuals shine and meet enterprise grade
requirements.
And of course, last but not least, we have agent
skills.
So the agent skills teaches your coding agent how to
use these packages and not just how to use them
in terms of building your dashboards and applications, but how
to use them effectively.
So building applications that actually have good taste.
Because let's be honest, we don't just want a functional
dashboard, we want something that is going to impress your
boss and impress anyone that's going to use it.
And so enough of me talking about what this is,
let's actually go and see a demo of this.
So let's start off here.
So our CEO love the app that Ben built.
So woo, good job Ben.
He really loved it.
But as any CEO, they always want more.
And so the next thing our CEO is asked is
build me an operational dashboard so I can see if
customers are actually loving this new delivery experience.
And so let's take a look at that experience.
So to start with, I'm in the Fabric portal.
And like I mentioned, this is about bringing that shared
experience for analytics and turning it into an application.
So in Fabric, I already have a ton of semantic
models and I want to build applications on top of
these semantic models.
And Ben showed you the CLI experience of how you
can do that.
But let's see how we can also start that from
within Fabric.
So to start with, let me go to my workspace
and then let me go ahead and click new item.
And here's where you're going to see that new artifact
type called app.
And let's go ahead and give this a name.
So I want this to be my analysis app.
I'm just going to go ahead and click create.
And you'll notice here you're going to give given a
few choice of templates here like Sachin mentioned is you
could start from the blank app, but might as well
make your job easier.
If you're trying to build a data app, start with
our template.
So if you pick the data app template, you're going
to automatically get the scaffolding to make sure that you're
able to query your semantic model, connect to it, and
also make sure that you get those enterprise grade visuals.
So once I have this template selected, I'm going to
go ahead and copy the prompt, and then I'm going
to switch over to VS Code.
So using Copilot and the coding agent within VS Code,
I'm going to go ahead and paste that prompt and
then I'm going to hit enter.
And so now what's happening is it's basically scaffolding that
data app so that I can get ready to build
my analytics app of of my choice.
And once the scaffolding is done, here's where the fun
part happens, because now all I need to do is
provide the requirements of what I'm trying to build.
So in this case, I want to build a a
analytics app so that I can look at the satisfaction
of my customers.
And so I'm using that existing semantic model.
So I just put a link to that semantic model
and I say that I'm trying to analyze the customer
satisfaction.
And because this is an app, I can also make
it really actionable.
So I can even add a button like a flag,
a flag button to be able to escalate issues to
my product team.
And just for some quick demo magic, I'm going to
quickly Fast forward some of this.
But of course, you may want to iterate with your
agent until you get your idea right.
And once that's done, let's go ahead and take a
look at the app we've built.
So let's open it up in Fabric.
And here you see a full blown analytics app that's
created with just a few prompts.
And the beauty of this too is I did not
have to prompt for the detailed things of, oh, I
want it to like look a certain way or move
this visual here, move this visual there.
Like I'm relying on the coding agent to do a
lot of this formatting for me.
So it saves me a ton of time.
And I also don't need to be a design expert
to create something that looks as polished as this.
And like I mentioned, because this is an application, you
know, you can get a lot more flexibility of being
able to have custom actions directly in your app.
So for example, I wanted to be able to flag
or escalate issues to the rest of my product team.
So the app added a button here or I added
a button here in the app to flag those issues
and go ahead and e-mail the product team.
So the beauty of what you're getting is you're getting
an analytics app that also combines the actions that you
would expect for any sort of data-driven application.
So what we're doing is really tying the loop between
how you take data and transform it into action.
And with that, I'll pass it back to Sachin.
Thanks.
All right.
So you saw 2.
Applications being built one more of an operational delivery app
and an analytics application and both of them use Rayfin
to define the data API, the back end and code
and then the services get deployed to Fabric.
So why is fabric so good?
About for building these applications, so one of the greatest
advantages.
Of fabric is that.
Everything inside Fabric already has your enterprise.
Grade security rules.
And compliance defined on all of these artifacts, right?
And one of the things in fabric.
Is that all of the artifact data?
Lives inside 1 Lake.
So the way to think about 1 Lake is that
it's the OneDrive for data.
And since this application is now also living in Fabric
using the fabric artifacts, that means all of your applications
data also lands in one lake.
Which means that if a business user wanted to get
access.
To this data to do.
Some data science or do downstream analytics.
They have easy access to get to this data as
well as the you can build applications that then consume
that data.
As well so this.
Kind of makes it really easy for both your applications
as well as your analytical data to kind of live
in the same security boundary.
Fabric by default is a SAS offering, so all the
infrastructure.
Is easy to.
Provision and there's not much for you to manage the
other thing about.
Fabric is the way you.
Consume anything as.
Fabric is you buy.
Fabric capacity and then you can assign a certain amount
of compute to any of those artifacts.
And now you can take the same capacity that you've
been using for your analytical workloads and you can also
assign it to your application.
So you know any database operations, any queries, all of.
Them get built towards.
One capacity, so you don't have to manage multiple meters.
While Fabric runs everything in the cloud.
When you're developing your application, you run things locally, right?
So anything that you're developing, be it functions or be
it your web app, anything that contains.
User code is developed locally.
And for the underlying services?
You have two options.
So you can either spin them up in a dev
workspace in Fabric or you can run it inside local
docker container which is currently experimental.
And when you do rafin up, it will package the
whole thing and then you can put it in a
production workspace and you can sort of use that same.
Workflow to also move.
From dev staging to production so you can create a
bunch of workspaces.
And fabric.
And you can develop in one and you feel good
about it.
You can take the same application and then move it
into staging, production and so forth and so.
Fabric is the easiest.
And best way for?
You to build secure.
Enterprise applications and operate on them, but we understand that
not that there might be a need for.
People to be able to self host.
The applications and so.
For that, we'll be.
Open sourcing part of our the race and runtime and
we look to the community.
To be able to build this with us so.
You can run the self hosted applications on various types
of infrastructure.
So it has changed the way that.
You know people.
Are building applications, but not just in terms.
Of how quick it is to go building applications, but
also who?
Can build an application and not everyone lives anymore inside
an IDE.
Or CLI replit.
Is one of the.
Easiest tools to use to go build and realize these
ideas.
And so we're.
Really excited to partner.
With Replit, I would like to invite Carl on stage.
Who's the tech?
Leader Replit to talk a lot more about this.
Everyone, I'm Carl and I'm the technical lead at Replit,
helping lead the integration with both Raefin and Fabric.
So for those who don't know, Replit is a gentic
browser based IDE where non-technical and semi technical users can
build apps.
So Rayfin and Fabric are great for the technical business
user who's extremely technical wants to get into the code.
But Replit's here for the users who don't maybe have
that coding experience who still want to be able to
build and deploy these apps.
Let's see, we do this with enterprise grade privacy and
security.
So all the apps that are built with Replit inherit
all of those same security properties that were just described.
Instead of talking about it though, let me show you
how it works.
So here's an example of building an app with Replit.
I'm going to spin up a dashboard for our stand
up in an hour.
I'm gonna give it the Power BI model, the semantic
model, and let the agent go to work.
Here you can see the model doing its work.
It looks at the schemas within that semantic model and
builds the dashboard, including the DAX queries underneath directly from
that content.
And then you can see we can deploy this directly
into our Rayfin environment.
So this is deploying into Rayfin and we'll have the
live app with the same workspace and item objects that
you would expect on the back end.
So you can manage this entirely from Replit for non-technical,
semi technical users.
Right now we're in private beta, so we have a
couple users using it.
And here's a quote from one of our test users,
Leatherman.
Leatherman is a company that's both an avid user of
Replit already and an avid user of Fabric.
And here's what they had to say.
We appreciate how quickly we can build and iterate with
Replit, but for some of our business, our data needs
to needs to stay governed and centralized in Fabric.
With Raefin, we finally have both fast development and the
tools we prefer and the confidence that our applications were
on top of our enterprise data platform.
This is exactly what we've been looking for.
So yesterday we announced the partnership between Reply to Microsoft
on stage with Satya.
And today I'm just wanted to be here and I'm
super excited and grateful to be working with the team
from Microsoft to kick this all off.
And I'm going to turn it back over to Ben
and he's going to wrap us up.
Thanks.
Thanks, Carl.
OK, So we've covered a lot in this session and
now I want to just sort of breakdown where we're
at, what's going to be released over the next couple
days and then sort of where we're going.
And so right now, the focus is really on making
it easy for people to build enterprise applications.
So giving you sort of all those core fundamental building
blocks to be able to do that, giving you the
database, the enterprise auth out-of-the-box, making it so it's easy
to deploy all of that to Fabric in a managed
tenant.
And then we're looking at, OK, where do we go
from there?
So very soon we will add support for functions, for
RBAC, for additional data connectors.
So you'll be able to connect to any data within
one lake and BLOB storage as well.
And so at that point, you'll really kind of have
the full suite of capabilities you need to run enterprise
applications.
So we will have moved from building largely internal applications,
sort of data dashboards, things like that to kind of
whatever you want to build within an enterprise tenant.
But we want to be able to do more than
that.
So as we look forward to the end of the
year, we want to support more B to B&B to
C scenarios.
And so that's where we move beyond just having intra
auth to having OIDC auth to having real time services.
We also want to make it easier and easier to
get started with Rayfin.
So we'll be letting you get started not using an
intra or a company ID, but you can actually use
a social log in to get started.
And we'll have a perpetual free tier offering as part
of that as well.
Right now you can go use Fabric for free to
get started as well.
So we encourage everybody to go do that.
OK?
So that's what's next for us.
What's next for you.
So there is one last Rayfin session available later today
at 3:00.
Chris Anderson from our team will be walking through it.
I love that.
And then the biggest thing we want though, is for
you to go try it.
So go kick the tires.
And OK, sorry about the team's messages coming up.
And we're really looking for the community to help build
this with us.
So we're looking for your feedback.
We want you to go try building apps right now.
So you can go to github.com, Microsoft Raefen to start
trying it and give us your feedback.
And then you can also sign up for the Replit
private preview as well and get started with that.
I'll just pause for a second there.
Let all my Teams messages go away.
All right, beautiful.
And so that's it from us.
Thank you so much for listening to the Rayfin talk
and we're really excited to go see what you build
with Rayfin.
Thank you all.